the show is trying to move on without
alex trebek all-time champ ken jennings
is guest host next week
and we hit ken with the final jeopardy
question i think that's on everybody's
mind
thank you ladies and gentlemen we can
break the news right now
are you going to be the next host of
jeopardy i don't think there's been
any decision because it's just such a
you know it's been such a rapidly
a developing situation you know
nobody expected to lose alex this sooner
you know we're still grieving about it
honestly the greatest of all time
jeopardy champion
i spoke to him shortly before he passed
actually and he was very
confident that i could you know that i
could do it i appreciated his trust
ken recently made headlines apologizing
after past
insensitive tweets resurfaced the 46
year old said he wants to own up to
unartful and insensitive things
i screwed up and i'm truly sorry e.t has
learned ken has already taped 30
episodes which he guest hosts
no word on if his twitter scandal will
affect his chances of getting the
full-time gig
the enormous shoes you're filling and
the the legacy there i take it very
seriously
looking ahead ken's promoting his new
quiz show the chase he's joined by
fellow jeopardy champs james holt tower
and brad redder
and host sarah hines for the quiz series
premiering thursday on abc
so how does it work contestants try to
outsmart the three trivia masters for
cold hard
cash you probably shouldn't have even
shown up
we'll see this show um has been on in
the uk for a while will there be tweaks
and differences
there are a few differences we have a
kind of setup where the two chasers are
inactive or watching backstage and
offering some kind of uh
you know trash talking commentary which
i just love this is still a competition
between the three of you
kevin it got a little fun because when
one of them missed a question
rarely happens it was fun to toss at
them that
someone else would have gotten that
right you're about to leave here
sorely disappointed do you prepare for
these days is there
are you just like sitting down with the
encyclopedia there's a little bit of
that uh but
mostly just paying attention to things
and having a certain interest in
knowledge what is it that america loves
about these games that make them really
think
when i was a kid watching jeopardy every
day after school like i was just amazed
by the contestants it's kind of seeing
like the limit of what
the trivia brain can do i got that big
brain energy